[Musique]
tout ça est remis dans un avion l'asile
politique et la huent en 2016 ou 2017 en
france il doit être levé il va être
envoyée chez monsieur déjà qu'on foute
ce mec dehors il est réfugié politique
il est venu demander l'asile
il se comporte comme un [ __ ]
[Musique]
moi je veux pas verser dans le
complotisme néanmoins je remarque que ya
quand même eu une certaine forme de
technicité il a sans doute été aidée je
suis pas sûr que ce soit le personnage
central de cette affaire
et aussi mauvais en ce qui concerne d'un
mot la russie je suis pas en train de
faire de complotisme j'ai horreur du
congrès donc l'idée de se demander si au
delà d'un artiste suicidaire provocateur
et probablement relevant de la
psychiatrie
il ya quelqu'un d'autre
[Musique]
moi je suis devenu l'avocat de benjamin
griveaux parce qu'il subit trois
poursuites en diffamation de la chaîne
arte france
j'entends beaucoup parler du russie dans
cette oeuvre
[Musique]
on ne peut pas faire la moindre
connexion entre les actions intentées
par rt france à l'encontre de l'ancien
secrétaire d'état et la sphère qui le
concerne
aujourd'hui les actions intentées par rt
france l'ont été dans le but est
uniquement dans le but de sauvegarder
l'honneur et la considération de ses
employés et journalistes
[Musique]
là aussi des parfois difficile d'être à
oui surtout quand on fait de la rotation
politique
c'est le cas de piotr pas vu un ch'ti
alors c'est un artiste qu'on connaît
déjà qui vient de se faire arrêter lundi
après avoir mixé aux portes en bois de
ce bâtiment qui abrite l'ancien kgb
[Musique]
il ya dans le contexte actuel de grandes
difficultés qui ont été causés par le
parquet dans l'exercice de sa défense il
ya des pièces qui ont été introduites au
dossier de façon à tenter de m'écarter
de sa défense
[Musique]